Which is better, long copy or short
copy? Well, you're asking the wrong
question. It's actually boring copy or
exciting copy? Because if you have a
two-page sales letter and it's
incredibly boring, still too long. But
if you have a 20page sales letter, it's
incredibly exciting. Then it's not long
enough. Let me explain. Look at this.
This is Harry Potter. Okay, this book,
you know how thick this is? This book is
about 800 pages long. 829 pages and this
is just one of seven books. JK Rowling
wrote seven books. Now, is that too long
or is too short? Well, you tell me.
Because people were waiting days in line
just to get the next copy and the next
copy and the next copy because they were
excited to read it. You need to start
thinking about your copy in more
storytelling excitement rather than just
boring sales features and benefits and
all this crap that no one wants to read.
Your job is to get them to read the next
line and the next line and the next
line. So, the answer is not short or
long. It's boring or exciting. And if
you missed it,